what if i told you that taylor swift
changed music forever and no i don't
mean by pioneering her own brand of
folksy yet accessible pop rock i mean
that she actually changed the way that
music gets made and the way that artists
are able to monetize the art that they
create it's actually true when people
look back on this age of music they're
going to think about the before taylor
swift age and the after taylor swift age
because as she found out the hard way
being a rock star comes with a lot of
perks but there's also a dark side
whatever time the d took place the
cavity wasn't there
no
not that dark but some of the most
legendary names in music have been
screwed by terrible deals with recording
companies bad contracts and greedy
labels have left artists like rick james
broke while companies made hundreds of
millions of dollars on their art and
taylor swift's most recent album
fearless taylor's version arrived at
number one on the billboard 200 and
promptly broke a bunch of industry
records this is nothing new for swift
she's been a star since she was a
teenager but it's the way that she
achieved these milestones that's worth
talking about when taylor lost control
of the music copyrights over her first
six albums she acted swiftly yes there's
going to be a lot of puns in this one
she acted swiftly by re-recording her
first album but why would any musician
re-record their album in a way that is
almost indistinguishable from the first
one well we can look to another example
like swift prince signed his first music
deal as a teenager he gave warner
brothers ownership over his entire back
catalog prince eventually sued and
changed his name to a symbol to try and
stop the company from profiting on his
name and eventually hoarded his music to
prevent corporations from taking control
of his work similarly paul mccartney
lost control of the beatles catalog in
the 1960s and has worked for decades to
get the rights to his original beatles
recordings and that project is still
ongoing and in this context swift's bold
decision to re-record her albums and
reclaim the value of her own music will
influence every artist of her generation
and for generations to come
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a greedy music label executive or i
guess an entrepreneurial musician lisa
leftie lopez once described the music
industry as a cutthroat business full of
greedy individuals who take advantage of
young artists she would know tlc was one
of the biggest acts in music when they
were forced to file for bankruptcy
because their original recording deal
got them just seven percent on the sale
of each album minus deductions for
touring and promotion understanding
music law is essential for any musician
or songwriter but it's not like there's
a school of music law and this is
daunting for most people who usually
have no experience in the law or
drafting legal contracts when they get
started in business and in the us the
music industry is governed by the
copyright act but it also operates by
tradition particularly in the music
publishing side of the business so to
understand what is so monumental about
what taylor swift has done and is
continuing to do we have to learn a
little bit about copyright law and the
music industry now to help understand
how this works let's talk about
hypothetical let's say you're a
promising singer-songwriter you write
your own music and record it in your own
studio but how do you get paid for your
music well it should be simple right you
write a song record it release it as a
digital download on your website or on a
cd or cassette tape or an lp if you're a
dirty hipster and you get paid when
someone buys it you get 100 of that
money yay however your ability to market
your own songs is limited how will
people discover you where will they buy
your stuff how do you get your songs on
the radio how will you afford to tour
what if you think your music would be
good in commercials or movies well this
is where labels and music publishers
have traditionally entered the picture
so congrats the legal eagle music label
screaming eagle wants to sign you for a
record deal i'm going to give you a
hundred thousand dollars in advance
you'll also assign 50 of your publishing
rights to screaming eagle music
publishing code which i own just sign
this legally binding contract and you'll
be well on your way to super stardom and
tomorrow 100 thousand dollars will be
transferred to your bank account sounds
pretty good right awesome awesome
awesome
awesome but wait before you say yes or
no you need to read the contract and
that's actually not what happened with
brad paisley because sony refused to
give brad paisley data on how many
albums he sold because contract footnote
said he couldn't challenge royalty
payments until 2006. he couldn't legally
get the numbers so the fine print
matters and in that case it was probably
shortchanged over 10 million dollars it
all starts with knowing the difference
between two different copyrights that
are involved in the creation of music
and side note there's actually at least
six different copyrights that are
involved when you're talking about the
creation and publication of music music
is particularly complex when it comes to
copyright law so for simplicity's sake
we're just going to talk about the two
main ones when it comes to creation
there is the musical work copyright and
there is the sound recording copyright
but what rights are these under the
copyright act 17 usc section 106 the
owner of a copyright in work has certain
exclusive rights to that work including
the rights to reproduce or copy that
work adapt and prepare derivative works
based on the original distribute copies
of it perform or display it publicly
perform a sound recording publicly by
digital audio transmissions etc and how
long do these exclusive rights last well
since your songs were created on or
after january 1st 1978 they last for 70
years after the death of the individual
author so let's talk about this first
right the music composition right or the
musical work copyright it protects the
underlying musical arrangement and the
accompanying lyrics of a song whether
that composition is fixed in written
sheet music recorded or otherwise in our
hypothetical you created a musical work
all by yourself so you own that
copyright until you sign the contract
assigning it to the screaming eagle
music publishing company and under our
proposed agreement i will let you keep
50 of the music composition rights but
that takes us to the second copyright
the sound recording copyright which
protects the actual recording of a
musical composition this could be a
recording that's contained in a cd an
mp3 file a computer hard drive
or other phono records the copyright act
uh needs to update its language but the
copyright act defines phono records as
material objects which sound is affixed
to by any method now known or later
developed and under this proposed
contract with the screaming eagle
records the label will pay for all of
the musicians and the equipment that you
need to record an album the official
finished sound recordings will be owned
by the record company this is the
version of the song that is publicly
released these are generally called
master recordings and screaming eagle
records will not need your permission
now or in the future to use these
particular records or to sell them how
valuable are the masters so valuable
that everyone wants a piece of this pie
it's become a popular practice for
producers and song engineers to demand a
percentage of the masters for the work
of their song and sometimes this is an
advantageous arrangement for musicians
but be careful because it will keep
eating into your split anytime that
recording is played somewhere else so to
recap under our deal which would not be
totally crazy in the music industry
screaming eagle owns your masters but
you get to keep 50 of the composition
rights so this seems like a pretty
reasonable deal right or is it music
publishing is not something that's
defined by the copyright statute it's a
music industry tradition and expectation
that a music publisher will manage the
composition rights music publishers help
leverage your songs to make money and
protect your catalog of songs from
infringement and generally speaking
music publishers have two significant
revenue streams there are mechanical
royalties and performance royalties a
music publisher can pitch your song to
other artists who may record them or
they can get music plugged into
advertisements video games movies and
the like this might be financially
lucrative but it still means that as the
musician you're giving up another slice
of the overall pie so when will the
individual artists start earning money
well first you've got to ensure that you
sell enough albums to make up the 100
000 advance that you signed when you
signed with the label that money was in
advance not a signing bonus and then you
have to repay the music label for any
expenses it paid to help record your
album promote it and set up your tour
tlc only got about 20 cents per album
after the label deducted for dancers
sound engineers video production tour
support and radio promotion left eye
said that the group made less than one
percent of the estimated 175 million
dollars in revenue that the group's
music generated so let that be a lesson
only after you pay back the label in
full will you start earning royalties on
your music but once the contract between
you and the first music label ends you
might be able to sign a more lucrative
deal elsewhere however the original
music label will own the masters of the
sound recordings in your albums for as
long as it states in the contract which
could be as long as your life and then
some the label will continue to get
revenue for the sale of each album and
digital download that includes any of
the original sound recordings and that
includes royalties or fees from the use
of the sound records in any movies films
tv shows or advertisements and now you
know enough about copyright law and the
music industry to understand what
happened with taylor swift and big
machine imagine that you signed a deal
like this when you were 15 years old
like taylor swift in 2019 swift was
named artist of the decade for the sixth
album she made between the ages of 15
and 24 mostly while she was signed to
the record label big machine and not
surprisingly this soon erupted to bad
blood but the trouble began when scooter
braun who works with the kardashian clan
and justin bieber purchased the music
label big machine braun and swift had
publicly feuded in the past and once the
sale went through that means that
swift's masters were owned by braun big
machine was estimated to be worth at
least 300 million dollars with swift's
catalog valued at about 140 million
dollars at the time so she was
responsible for almost half the
company's value but this was not a love
story no
god
no god please no when her contract was
up swift opted not to re-sign with the
company but big machine was not exactly
thrilled with her decision to sign with
another label so she says that they
retaliated against her by refusing to
allow her to perform her songs on tv and
blocking her from using her recordings
in the netflix documentary about her
life although the label denied this the
new york times got an email showing an
executive from big machine telling
swift's representatives that the company
will quote not agree to issue licenses
for existing records or waivers of its
recording restrictions in connection
with the netflix documentary yes taylor
brought the receipts the lesson don't
second-guess a mad woman
[Applause]
oh boy
now swift tried to buy her masters from
big machine but braun refused to sell
them to her at any price braun wanted
swift to sign an nda muzzling her right
to talk about him as a condition of
negotiating swift said no deal but this
is a dilemma faced by many artists who
try to buy back their copyrights in the
late 1960s paul mccartney lost his stake
in northern songs the publishing company
that he'd set up with john lennon
mccartney also lost control over the
master recordings for the beatles and
when mccartney worked with michael
jackson in the 1980s he told jackson
that it was important to own the rights
to his own music jackson apparently
jokingly responded by saying one day
i'll own all of your music and mission
accomplished jackson responded to this
advice by buying up the mccartney
copyrights for himself in a backstabby
joint venture with sony atv that cost
him 47 million dollars for those of us
who like living dangerously
this one's for you mccartney of course
got nothing from the deal it also
shocker apparently ruined the mccartney
jackson friendship now the value of the
beatles catalog sword in 2016 sony atv
bought the jackson share of the beatles
songs for a whopping
750 million dollars but after years of
litigation over whether british or
american copyright law applied to the
sale mccartney finally got the chance to
get his rights back using the
termination provisions of the copyright
act which generally gives an artist an
opportunity to terminate transfers 35
years after the date of transfer but
what did this mean for taylor swift well
it meant that she decided to be
proactive right now to avoid ever being
in a mccartney situation which brings us
to why she re-recorded her albums 17
months after scooter braun purchased big
machine he sold the master tapes of
swift's albums to a private investment
fund the purchase price was a minimum of
300 million dollars which could escalate
to 450 million if certain benchmarks
were met the investment funds have been
scooping up music rights left and right
because their value is so high for
example in 2020 a firm purchased a 50
stake in rick james's catalog including
both publishing and recorded masters the
song super freak is still one of the
most sampled riffs in music and is still
probably worth tens of millions of
dollars if not more but when james died
in 2003 he left an estate worth just 250
000
the investment firm that purchased the
swift masters includes the george soros
family 23 capital and the carlisle group
according to swift they have not reached
out to her at all which is a strange
business decision since swift is making
them money swift wrote scott borchetta
told my team that they'll allow me to
use my music only if i do these things
if i agree not to re-record copycat
versions of my songs next year which is
something i'm both legally allowed to do
and looking forward to and also told my
team that i need to stop talking about
him and scooter braun braun's response
to swift's specific allegations was
basically
he posted about kindness on instagram
and had the goal to assert that taylor
communicating with her fans quote
greatly affects the safety of our
employees and their families so swift
just responded by re-recording her
original albums because remember there's
two different copyrights at work here
there is the composition license the
sheet music the melodies the lyrics and
then there is the copyright in the sound
recording itself she didn't own the
copyright in the sound recording big
machine and eventually the private
equity firms did but she did own the
composition license so she just took the
compositions and re-recorded them
effectively swift owned the abstract
version of the songs and she had the
funds available to work in a studio to
re-record it herself she could hire the
engineers and the other musicians to
help out on the album and she could just
make one that sounded identical to the
original album you might ask how does
this re-recording impact the original
masters that are now owned by a private
equity firm well it dilutes their values
fans are buying the new version of the
album in fact it went to number one on
the billboard charts it also means that
fans will stream the new versions
reducing the number of plays that the
original version gets on streaming
services and any company that wants to
license taylor swift's albums can now
work directly with swift which cuts off
income to the firm that owns the
original masters and you might think
that the two different versions of the
sound recordings might compete with each
other driving the price down but in
reality people generally want to work
with the original artist because that
artist is going to continue making new
art that they might want to license in
the future it's generally better for a
movie game or tv show to license the new
version because they would have a good
relationship with taylor swift who has
an entire career in front of her so
taylor swift made extremely important
business decisions that will not only
impact her but other artists as well the
private firm that owns the original
albums also probably missed an
opportunity if they had reached out to
smooth things over with swift the value
of the original masters would be intact
instead her fans are buying the new
album which sounds identical to the
original swift plans to re-record her
other five albums as well and a big
machine is bitter i guess that they can
just shake it off what advice would you
give to anyone who wants to become a
singer
get a good lawyer
if only i knew some music producer who
could listen to the originally recorded
masters and compare them to the taylor
swift recorded versions man that would
be a really interesting thing to learn
especially if i knew the most preeminent
music producer on youtube man that would
be great
rick as the preeminent
music educator on youtube would you mind
listening to the original version of
taylor swift's fearless and compare it
to the new version to see if there's any
differences i will so here's the uh
original one that was recorded and put
out in 2008
okay if i just listen in the beginning
let's check the new one
[Music]
way better snare sound
[Applause]
sounds fuller
this actually isn't fair because i
listened to the two of them back to the
back and the new one is far superior
taylor's voice sounds better the
recording's better they did a really
great version of it and the snare drum
is is much better in the new one
that's that's incredible that that you
can hear that much of a difference
between the the two versions they're
they're pretty identical tempo wise they
must have actually overlaid them so that
they got the the the tempo right on but
you know they probably have a lot of the
same i've looked but i would imagine
maybe they have some of the same players
playing on them but the the sonically
the new one is far better and i think
her voice sounds better on it so over
time you think that she's become a
better singer absolutely no question
about it interesting well uh i hope that
this particular video doesn't get a
copyright claim but if it does then i
will dispute it just like we did on your
channel uh when we went through and
disputed all of the copyright claims
that you got on your videos because it's
this video is fair use there you go
so there you have it to a layperson the
two songs sound pretty similar but to
the trained ear you might even say that
the new versions that are engineered by
taylor swift herself sound even better
than the originals her voice has matured
the technology has gotten better so if
that's the case why would you even
listen to the original masters why not
just always listen to the taylor swift
version but the question is what is
taylor going to do with all of that
extra money well she'll probably spend
it on a great meal but we know that
taylor likes to do things herself so her
best bet is today's sponsor hellofresh
now i am also a do-it-yourself person
and i have to say i was initially pretty
skeptical about hellofresh i'm a pretty
good cook so i didn't think i needed the
help but i actually loved it even for an
experienced cook like me hellofresh
delivers new ingredients and recipes
that i'd never try on my own everything
i've gotten from hello fresh was
insanely delicious easy to cook and
really healthy for example i recently
made yogurt marinated chicken with
garlic sauce pork tenderloin with cherry
sauce and meatloaf all a mom and every
single one of those was fantastic and
not something that i would have made on
my own so if you feel like you've been
cooking the same thing every day in
quarantine hellofresh is a great
solution and of course everything was
delivered straight to my door so i
didn't have to do any shopping and
what's really great is the produce
actually gets to you faster than it
would if you bought stuff from a grocery
store so it arrives at peak freshness
and flavor and it's also super easy to
save time hellofresh cuts out meal
planning and prep so the recipes only
take 20 to 30 minutes to cook literally
less time to cook than it would normally
take to do the shopping and it's also
incredibly sustainable since the
ingredients are pre-portioned there's
less prep and less wasted food the
package is almost entirely made from
recyclable or already recycled content
and hellofresh's carbon footprint is
actually 25 lower than that of meals
made from store-bought groceries so if
you'd like to try hello fresh and i
really recommend that you give it a try
you can go to hellofresh.com and use the
code legaleagle14 to get 14 free meals
yes you can actually get 14 free meals
plus free shipping or you can just click
on the link below so again for 14 free
meals go to hellofresh.com and use the
code legaleagle14 or just click on the
link that's on screen right now plus
clicking on this link really helps out
this channel and while you're at it
click on this playlist over here with
all my other real law reviews with
explanations of today's legal news so
click on this link or i'll see you in
court